le réseau de chaleur et de froid paris
saclay pourquoi avoir fait ça pour trois
raisons d'abord c'est une énergie locale
ce qui était une garantie forte
deuxièmement c'est une énergie
renouvelable et propre décarbonés très
bonne performance environnementale et
troisièmement c'est une énergie a pris
contrôle et nous en connaissons le coup
aujourd'hui et demain il n'ya pas d'aléa
de marché sur ce sur le coup cet
économiste une grande sécurité pour ceux
qui vont devoir se chauffer ou se
refroidir sur le plateau le système est
basé sur la géothermie donc il s'agit
d'aller récupérer à 700 mètres de
profondeur de l'eau à 28 degrés on va
faire circuler dans une boucle dit
réseau tempérer cette boucle de tempérer
va permettre de produire de la chaleur
du froid mais aussi aux bâtiments
d'échangés de l'énergie je pense qu'il
serait excédentaire ou déficitaire dans
leur profil visage l'ensemble de ce
réseau irrigue une centaine de bâtiments
qui vont être tous connectés à une fibre
optique dit fibre énergie qui va
permettre de créer le smart grid campus
saclay et tous les bâtiments vont
pouvoir agir sur un système global entre
la production et leurs besoins de
manière à optimiser la consommation
d'énergie de chaque bâtiment
nous avons sur ce site existants et à
venir des bâtiments avec un profil
énergétique très particulier qui ont des
processus lourd pour pour créer du froid
et qui donc rejettent du show grâce à la
boucle que nous allons créer dans le
cadre de ce réseau ce show ne sera pas
perdue lui envoyer dans l'atmosphère est
remis sur la boucle pour chauffer les
voisins
le projet de réalisation de cet ouvrage
cette infrastructure s'étale sur cet
enjeu donc de 2016 à 2021
on va créer une vingtaine de kilomètres
de réseau une centaine de sous stations
une centrale géothermique et des
centrales d'appoint secours pour fournir
le chaud le froid et garantir la
continuité du service toute l'année
le réseau de chaleur et de froid
paris-saclay va très vite devenir une
réalité
nous avons la contrainte est quelque
part la chance d'être tirée par les
premiers arrivés de bâtiments sur le
plateau et vous voyez que les chantiers
sont aujourd'hui nombreux sur le plateau
ces bâtiments qui sont en train de
sortir de terre seront desservies par le
réseau de chaleur et de froid et donc le
déploiement de cette infrastructure
énergétique est déjà engagée et doit
aller très vite pour pouvoir les
satisfaire